how do you find like your passion in
life and what's your like you know
advice for people to find it I think
people are struggle with passion because
they overthink the financial part of it
so a lot of people's passion is cooking
video games gardening watching movies
but their brain says I can't build a
business watching movies and how to
fining you love I think you know the
answer I bet you she can tell me things
you like all what you told about cooking
games he likes them all you just started
from all of all of them Gregory all of
them can be the business but you don't
think it can and then you once you
realize that then you start making
content just got to make